oh here how was your conversation with  my dad I did ask him for a blessing at  the end of this if we get there for an  engagement um I didn't get his approval  you didn't I didn't  I didn't know he was not gonna yeah  and you're okay with that him telling me  that I don't have his busting it does  not discourage me at all in US and it  will not change the way that I continue  to feel about you  then um I had no idea that he asked him  my dad said no I know I and no clue it's  really important that my dad approves  I'd not think you did wouldn't I don't  get it and then it makes me like  confused if he's the right person or if  we just need more time I don't think  I've ever been so confused  cause I'm in this big  [Music]  [Applause]